so there's not a direct link clearly
between the geology and they and
people's votes but there is this
wonderful chain of cause and effect
through hundreds of years of human
history and then millions of years of
our planet's history and what was
happening on the planet 75 to 80 million
years ago in a chapter of Earth's
history called the Cretaceous is the sea
levels were much much higher back then
the ocean lapped right up through the
middle of North America and a great
interior sea and laid down what was
essentially thick deposits of seafloor
mud which became compacted down buried
by more recent structure of rocks and
then eroded away again and exposed along
this particular arc in the southern
states to the north are rocks older to
the south they're younger these are the
Cretaceous age rocks and when that
rocker roads to create soil it gives you
a very rich fertile dark soil and is
realized in the early 1800s that that
soil is phenomenally productive a
growing cash crops like cotton which as
we've already mentioned unfortunate this
period of history meant slave labor
cotton is incredibly finicky to harvest
it's not like cotton or rice we can
simply chop it off at the stalk take it
out of your field and then shake a bit
to get the grain that you want cotton
requires fingers and even today after
hundreds of years of after the Civil War
and emancipation and freedom from
slavery in the civil rights movement
even today is that Cretaceous band of
rocks that has the highest density of
black African Americans living there
today people unfortunately still suffer
still have blighted with social economic
problems of poor wages poor health care
poor social structures people that are
therefore more likely to vote for
Democrats election promises rather than
Republican and in fact the city I've
marked here Montgomery is where 1955
Rosa Parks refused to give up her seat
to white gentlemen on the bus the very
epicenter of the entire civil rights
movement the transformed Society in
politics
the whole of the United States began
smack in the middle of rocks at 18
million years old on the surface
you